welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
Daniel Kenaston an assistant professor
of economics at Yale University
professor Kenna stands research focuses
largely on the role and structure of
markets in developing countries with
other interests in governance technology
adoption and economic history today we
talk with Professor Kenniston about two
recent studies he's conducted in India
on reforming police departments and
deterring drunk driving welcome
professor Kenaston thanks so much as a
pleasure to be here let's begin talking
about the study you have worked on in in
terms of the reform and police stations
in Rajasthan what gave you the idea to
do the study well we initially met some
of the very senior officers in the
police and they had a feeling that they
weren't getting good feedback on how
effective their reform projects were so
individual officers would come up with a
reform project and then they would
implement that project and while they're
implementing it their subordinates would
say that it was the greatest thing that
ever happened to the police but as soon
as they got transferred to somewhere
else the project would stop functioning
entirely so they wanted to bring in some
outside agencies to help give them a
much more scientific evaluation of the
effectiveness of various reform projects
that they were doing okay and give us an
overview of the project I know there
were four different parts of it yeah we
tried four different approaches to
reforming the police all kind of aimed
at improving the police efficiency and
also improving how the population viewed
the police so the first thing we did was
just a general training approach where
we took some officers and we gave them
both kind of public relations training
as well as more concrete investigative
training sort of a refresher on how to
collect fingerprints or refresher on how
to collect genetic material that sort of
thing the second thing we did was we
froze all transfers of police from
station to station so any police officer
there was no police station had to stay
there for
well up to two years and this was
because as of now and actually in
Rajasthan in all of India transfers are
used as a way of kind of rewarding
favorite favorites and punishing people
who are kind of down in the police
through those kind of backdoor channel
so there's some locations that are
better like than others maybe it's in a
big city or maybe it's in an area which
has a lot of potential for collecting
corruption money sure and those are used
as a reward whereas other ones in rural
areas or where there's less corruption
potential are used as punishment so what
we try to do is eliminate that channel
by stopping all transfers for two years
in addition to that we implanted some
more stuff within the police stations
that were a little similar so we also
made a duty rotation system within the
police station and attach that to a 24
of the 24 hour break every week so
actually as of in fact as of now
currently the police in India don't ever
get a day off and are on duty 24 hours a
day oh my goodness so we wanted to test
and see you know if we actually scale it
down a little bit that has made them
work only six days a week rather than
seven days a week would they be more
productive for the remaining six days a
week and also we rotated the duties they
did within the station and finally we
did a fourth intervention which was a
community observer so the idea was that
it every day in the month a new person
from the community would come in and
just sit in the police station for three
hours and they weren't supposed to you
know do any work or do anything like
that they were just supposed to see how
the police operated and the idea there
was sort of twofold on the one hand we
wanted to give some members of the
community especially more influential
members like the local high school
principal or local doctors that kind of
thing a sort of some insight into the
house police did their job in non crisis
situations because we felt that most
people only saw the police when
something was bad like they were getting
arrested or there was a crime or
something like that on the other hand we
also wanted to ensure that for at least
a few hours in the day other potential
crime victims are that kind of thing
could come into the police station and
know that there was another member of
the community there so if there for
example intimidated by the police or
thought they were being forced to pay a
bribe they could go during this
three-hour period when there was a
community observer there and know that
they wouldn't be
alone in the police station those were
the four different interventions that we
that we experiment okay you also as part
of your study conducted a crime survey
which my understanding is it's the first
that's been that was ever done in India
talk a little bit about that yeah that's
right so in places like the US or Europe
or really almost all developed countries
crime is measured primarily through a
household survey so many people out
there in America maybe not us but some
people are going to interviewed every
year about whether there are victims of
crimes in India that's not the case
ninja crime is measured by the number of
crimes that are reported to the police
so this leads to kind of a perverse
situation where for a certain police
officer or even a politician wants to
reduce crime all they have to do is stop
actually registering the cases in their
log books and crime is automatically
lower in fact it's even more perverse
than that because if for example the
local police doesn't seem very friendly
to the population or it's intimidating
or that kind of thing local population
may just not even bother to report a
crime and it will seem as if crime is
lower in that case as well so because of
this perverse incentive the whole crime
reporting system in India is actually
encouraging the police to do their jobs
in the bad way so what we wanted to do
was pilot a system where we would
actually collect data on crime in India
in a way that was much more similar to
the way it's collected us actually a
house-by-house survey on whether people
had been a victim of a crime okay did
you was this something we've done
through the mail or did you visit
household no we actually hired a lot of
people who went literally door-to-door
to randomly selected households as is
done in the US and asked people whether
they had been a victim of one of many
different types of crimes right so what
were what were some of your findings of
the study so well we found several
different things first of all the crime
the crime interview found the crime
survey found that indeed crabs were very
largely under reported in India and
different categories different amounts
of random reporting and what we found in
the effect of our interventions was
actually very interesting so some of
them didn't work at all the bringing
them remember the community didn't work
at all the weekly day off and Duty
rotation no effect we did find some
small effects of the freeze on transfer
and the training particularly on
people's reported fear of the police and
also on how satisfied crime victims were
with how the police have dealt with
their cases but i think the real sort of
broad takeaway of this was that those
the two interventions that did work that
is the freeze on transfers in the
training or ones that could be
implemented much more from the top down
on the other hand the others the the
community observers and the weekly
offered the Duty rotation required the
head of the police station the police
chief at that individual station to kind
of buy-in and what we found was that
there was people the local police chiefs
were very resistant to the whole program
because they saw that they didn't feel
that there was anything in for them and
they also felt that they would be
transferred very soon maybe you know in
a year so they didn't believe in the
freeze on transfers they thought they'd
be transferred very soon and they didn't
see that there was any need to there's
any gain for them for investing serving
the long-term relationship with the
community or the long-term morale of the
other police staff in that police
station by implementing these programs
because they felt they would just leave
very soon right right well that doesn't
bode very well for the community I would
imagine then unfortunately not all right
right okay let's talk about another
study you've done about deterring
drugged driving driving in the same area
of Rajasthan and I'm curious did this
study grow out of the work you did
initially with the police reform yes it
absolutely did so our first police
reform project was very broad we were
trying to you know broadly reform the
whole relationship of the police with
the community and as I mentioned you
know we were only partially successful
in that so for a second work with the
police I think both we and the police
felt that it was time to focus on
something much more quantifiable and
direct so we chose drunken driving which
was a priority of the police at that
time and in particular one of the things
we did in the second study that built
off of what we learned about the
importance of motivating the staff is
particularly to lower levels was to try
experimenting with giving some police
staff extra incentives to actually do
the sobriety checkpoints that they were
assigned so in fact we learned from the
experience that really what the radisson
police value is a good transfer so that
we took some police and we offered them
a transfer to a more desirable location
if they performed well in forcing
drunken revelry to actually try to use
that perverse incentive in as a sort of
as a carrot to surprise yeah well we
don't tell it that yes and and part of
this was also a first because it's the
first time you conducted randomized
evaluations of sobriety checkpoints and
it's one of it's one of the only
policing experiment experiments in the
developing world so you know you're
doing a lot of new stuff over there
which i think is great so you know kind
of give us an overview how did how did
the study work yeah so that yeah I mean
more broadly you know these police
experiments have been done in the US but
sort of at a very slow rate and actually
much more in the 60s and 70s so we're
kind of taking that literature and
applying it to India but also extending
it a lot and you know what we found on
the on the road blocks was one of the
things we were testing was whether it's
better to have surprise roadblocks so
where the population doesn't know where
the police are going to do it or to
always have a roadblock at say the most
dangerous location may be right outside
the area where all the bars are that
kind of thing you could imagine you know
that really if you want to stop people
it's obvious we should put the roadblock
and everybody expects her to be a
roadblock there no one will drive drunk
on that section of road so what we found
was actually that the surprise
checkpoints were more effective the pink
Putin people on their toes works better
and in particular we actually were able
to document or quantify the effect that
if you put up a fixed roadblock it
becomes less effective over time because
people actually learn where it is
whereas a surprise road blocks where
didn't we didn't see the kind of
learning effect there we managed to keep
people sufficiently surprised that they
didn't figure out you know where to go
good boy yeah that makes sense to me but
curiously and this in this country you
know I often read in newspapers around
holiday times that there's going to be
you know a checkpoint at such and such a
location and that always I always
wondered why they do that I think
probably has to do with
some kind of legal issues would be my
guess but that wasn't wasn't necessarily
the case in India well actually
different countries do a different ways
so a particularly interesting example is
the French who initially made the
locations of their radar guns secret and
then told everyone where the radar guns
were in order to make them apprentice
was speeding at those exact points and
then made them secret again so this is
clearly kind of a policy question that
different police departments haven't
really figured out is whether you should
go surprise or fix that you know it
seems like some departments in us as you
suggested are moving in the more fixed
direction but certainly for enforcing
speed on highways you know in the US
Highway Patrol's have very much taken up
the surprise sure right exactly so what
can we take away from this drunk driving
study well I mean I think there that
really you know the surprise approach is
more effective and another thing that we
did was we also like i mentioned
compared these police staff that we had
incentivized with the promise of you
know future good postings with just
normal police staff who had no greater
incentive to work then the police
normally do have and there we found that
indeed the incentivized a for doing much
much better i think thats gets at a much
broader issue in governance in
developing countries which is that
there's very rarely individual
incentives either for government
bureaucrats and developing countries or
for police certainly never the types of
attentive you would see in like a firm
in the US or something where you know
your bonus depends exactly on your
performance and I think incorporating
those even in a relatively mild way
through the offer of future positive
transfers at a very substantial effect
on outcomes I think that's something
that could be generalized to much more
areas of grammar that's post in
developing it do you think based on the
two studies that you've done they will
perhaps begin to incorporate more more
carrots so to speak in terms of getting
the police to do certain things yeah
absolutely we hope so I mean India is
now India has never had a dedicated
highway patrol on there now setting one
up and we're in contact with the people
who are you know developing that in
developing the institution of the
Highway Patrol
and they're very interested in this
research and trying to build a high
building some of the some of the results
of this research into the highway did
they contact you because they knew about
the studies yeah so we we now have many
connections within the police in India
and they have heard about it through
that excellent um did you encounter any
surprises in either study that you
weren't anticipating or expected I think
you know this the surprise was how
similar the police is to say a firm in
the US in many ways you know we expected
that the police would work in a very
military militaristic structure where
the incentives or motivations of the
lower down the staff Lord down in the
ranks weren't that important for
functioning they would just follow
orders but what we found was indeed you
know their their incentives matter a lot
and keeping them making sure that
whatever project you do provides them
with some immediate rewards is very
important much more important than we
thought it was going to be when we
started out where we thought they would
just follow orders blend very
interesting thank you very much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work my pleasure happy to
talk about it for more information about
professor canesten and his research
please visit our website at yale edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale